you look at some of the writings of  people like thomas jefferson  who realized how important it was  for people to maintain freedom  and even though he had slaves  and several of the founders had several  didn't but several did  most of them  ended up freeing their slaves  and  i think  realizing the internal conflict  when you're saying that all men are  created equal  but then you have slaves  but  you know those who hate the united  states have tried to make slavery  a unique issue for us and they say we  are particularly evil because we had  slavery  but if you know anything about  world history  you know that virtually every society  has adults with slavery  and that there are more slaves in the  world today than there have ever been at  any point in time when you look at human  trafficking